[Music]
hi developers my name is Jeff and I'm a
software engineer working on open source
at Google I'm alpha and I'm a lab
developer at pivotal I hope your Cloud
Foundry series is going great so far you
and I are going to spend the next few
episodes talking about cloud foundry and
stackdriver stackdriver is Google suite
of logging monitoring and developer
tools I'm going to be joined by experts
who know way more than I do about cloud
foundry and stackdriver so alpha can you
give us a little background about how
cloud foundry is deployed sure thing
Jeff Koz foundries made up of many
services that were not a non from data
center or the beam infrastructure of a
cloud hosts such as Google cloud
platform these services are deployed of
jobs by Bosh to several VMS and together
they form a working cloud foundry so
we've got all these applications that
must be doing tons of logging in
addition to Linux services logging the
syslog how can an operator make sense of
all that great question every boss job
right logs on no location on the
instance so an operator can use
debauched CLI to grab a recent set of
logs or streams about they come in this
fantastic for initial setup but
operators really need to set up a
long-term solution for monitoring of
sawing logs that's why we work together
with pivotal to develop these
stackdriver tools Bosh release this drop
in solution gives operators long-term
access to this information in
stackdriver logging and monitoring we
work together in Seattle using a pivotal
process we collocated once a week in our
office on once a week and yours and
together we develop the effect of a
novel tooling that enables cloud foundry
to talk to fax driver we did this all
out in the open and it was a lot more
fun than I thought it was going to be
now hear me out we had a lot of folks
who knew about Bosch couple focusing
about cloud foundry and go a little bit
of gcp of course but not a lot of
overlap by pair programming we're able
to spread that knowledge across and we
all came out with a much better
understanding of each other's products
so alpha can you pair with me and show
me how to set up stackdriver tools on
cloud foundry let's get through it first
let's upload your staff driver to relief
to our boss director from
open source project hosted on github now
what's the modify our deployment
manifest to include the relief the two
jobs Google fluency and sector of agent
will need to be collocated on the
instances that you want monitored after
that what's the run Bosh deploy of usual
and we can really version of the Bosh we
should be able to deploy this as an
add-on wow that's the fastest Bosh
deploy that ever happened editing is a
real miracle it might take a few minutes
on your machine so now that we've got
jobs running across our cloud foundry
which means our host logs and metrics
should appear in stackdriver let's make
our data a little more interesting by
waiting a week or so well that was
bypassed great let's dive in as log
stream in we can view and go down to
specific events these laws include all
it's a fog output from the instances in
a deployment as a lot of the logs from
any other boss job on the instance each
entry contains contacts including the
job name which allows operators to
easily filter and search through logs
all these logs come from the google
fluency job that we deployed earlier as
for the stack driver agent that's
responsible for gathering host metrics
with collecti and sending them back to
stack driver monitoring i'm going to hop
into stackdriver monitoring and we can
now see detailed information about our
cloud foundry infrastructure let's take
a look at the dashboard I created
earlier the dashboard shows metrics
gathered by the agent now we can look
for abnormalities and set up alerting
threshold such as high memory usage this
is a great start to having a single pane
of glass for a CF operator these
deployments are made up of tons of
virtual machines for having a heart beat
like this is a great thing to keep an
eye on let's look at the log metrics
we've created this metric is based off
of an event appearing in the stack
driver log we can drill into the actual
log events where this occurred this
gives us a query in the stack driver
logging compal specific to our event and
time range I'm going to filter to our
specific virtual machine and remove the
event filters to gain some context this
is an incredibly useful tool for keeping
an eye on your entire system and
drilling down when something pops up
that's host monitoring with stackdriver
and check out the description for more
resources on integrating cloud foundry
with stack driver
[Music]
thank you all for watching check out
some more videos we've done about
stackdriver and cloud foundry and check
out our pilots for even more information
make sure to subscribe to the Google
cloud channel right here